you by mafia three family is who you die
for
greetings screen jockeys whoo I'm so
excited to be here live in San Diego
with all of you for one of the most the
panels I'm most excited about guys I are
you guys know who Doug Benson is yeah I
have been such a fan as for such a long
time he's been so gracious and come on
our show movie flights quite a few times
and when we started screen junkies plus
which is our streaming service have a
bunch of cool shows there was always one
person I wanted to try and figure out it
exclusively do something fun and
original with and that fellow was Doug
Benson
I'm so excited to tell you because we
have some news we're gonna reveal but
I'm most excited because he's here and
he's brought some special friends but
first I'm gonna bring out the man of the
hour mr. Doug Benson come on out Doug
thank you so much for doing this come on
have a seat
whatever one you want you're the boss
they seemed like they should be lined up
one for each chair but anyway I have an
extra one free Mike's just don't like
cities they throw at us aren't they
supposed to your audience I didn't wear
shorts because I was trying to be
professional though this desk was gonna
hide everything this is pretty sweet
unbuckle my pants I can see do it relax
and have it have a great panel so yeah
so I've been on movie fights a few times
I do alright on there and I have a good
time stress you out that show yeah I
don't you know I competitive arguing
isn't really my thing I'd rather just be
like I didn't like it man
or whatever you know so I like on those
movies my movie podcast thank you very
much we you know we talked about movies
but we don't really get into arguments
about it unless the prequels come up and
then that's gonna be an argument but you
know somebody likes them but if who
likes them is just one guy I have
the show that's a I call most our Wars
prequel apologist and he thinks they're
as good or better than the first
yeah he's nuts so anyway but that
lunatic we don't we don't really have
arguing so much and then we we play
games on the show movie themed games and
there's a new game we've been playing
that I think is really fun and we'll
play a round of it here today ooh
at the end of this presentation but
first we have to talk about screen
junkies yeah so you have you heard of
screen junkies or when I bugged you you
found out about it then I'm just curious
who me yeah well I had heard of honest
trailers okay and knew that that was a
thing and that was very popular and I
might have heard about movie fights but
when you came to me and said I we do
this thing called movie fights you know
that I was in right away just because
you know it sounded super fun and it is
it is yeah and you've been very fun on
it and I love your energy on that show
because you do you take it very
seriously but you're calmer about it
some people get really upset myself
included during that show but yeah so
you I'm excited because we've been we've
been sort of teasing this for a while
but we're finally going to do a show
together on screen junkies Plus that's
right you guys guys my own show where
you gotta get you got to sign up and be
a member of screen junkies Plus to see
the show you do and if they sign up
today it's the best deal ever 50% off an
annual subscription it's like two bucks
a month you get it for the whole year
I'm telling you I don't know what's the
promo code someone tell me the promo
code esterday central 16 if you're going
through Dickies calm but I'm telling you
this next few days is the time to buy
one and try us out because you're
getting it at a steel I've been told
we're never gonna have it that low again
but yes it's gonna be a plus and I'm
really excited because we've been
shooting some of them do you what should
I set it up or do you want to set it up
I'll set it up I don't care it's coming
it's gonna debut sometime like late
August early September we're shooting
for and the show is called pitch off
with Doug Benson and the premise of the
show is what if I was a studio executive
and all my friends had to
pitch their movie ideas to me and I
could say yes or no to whether or not a
movie would exist like for example if
someone had come to me and said we're
gonna reboot Ghostbusters and pretend
the first Ghostbusters never happened
I'd say no pretend the first one
happened and continue the story but now
with now with some ladies and I would
have fixed that's that movie's problem
so I think it's gonna be very good for
all of Hollywood to see my Joey you
should be able to handle these things I
really should be in charge but yeah a
lot of it's very high just arbitrary
opinions and stuff and we have a teaser
trailer of clips from the show well we
brought a comic-con exclusive Doug
it's a comic-con exclusive only people
have watered it in this bar let's roll
the trailer for pitch ha look at it when
Hollywood runs out of ideas for movies
there's only one man who can answer the
call that's it it's me Doug Benson host
of the new screen junkies show pitch off
guys we need a sequel to Shawshank
Redemption a sports playing Guy Fieri
movie and it's got to be a musical title
Space Shuttle Beyonce what else you got
speed three brisk pace where contestants
take their fake pitches and throw them
at me a fake studio executive in hopes
of getting a fake movie deal in fake
Hollywood and they go in this black hole
and all of a sudden oh there's like
infinite white people I like it and I
love it
so this work
check out pitch off okay have a nice day
bye screen junkies pitch off with Doug
Benson exclusively on screen junkies
pause
I can vouch I was there it's very fun
and you brought some amazing people
who'd you bring what do you mean you
brought all your friends we got Steve
Agee
we got oh I didn't know there was gonna
be a quiz on who the guests were Graham
was there we just had a bunch yeah they
were still slowing down and my friend
Jeff Tate my executive assistant for the
day and yeah it was really bad at that
job yeah we're probably fire him and
then ya know that's kind of what the
show is but to give a little bit more of
a taste of it yes one of the people that
came in on the first episodes is Hal
Rudnick you guys know how Rudnick screen
junkies yeah and he well let's just show
it if they can
yeah he's paid example of round Roenick
tried one and round one of pitch-off who
doesn't love Shawshank Redemption
pitched me the sequel Shawshank
Ultimatum you might think warden Norton
killed himself
no did his son played by Joaquin Phoenix
in Phoenix
anything you're responsible for my
father's death he's gonna get the most
hardcore murderers killers life takers
double-crossers and bounty hunters to
find what a double crossers doesn't seem
as intense as all those other ones ratch
the double cross I'm eliminating that's
my pitch red says I think our goose is
cooked Andy and Andy says red
I've been digging again so he goes to
the wall and pulls off a poster of
Pamela Anderson and right there there's
a tunnel into the mountain and then red
says and do it in the morning for you
boys
I can dig it
yeah yeah yeah I think you approve that
one when you when you're pitching to me
you got to do the voices the idea sort
of came from because you've done in a
movie fights too but we have these pitch
rounds and moving flights and I just
thought how do we do that full-time and
then I thought this would be what a man
to sort of judge that so it's fun so if
you like to pitch rounds and movie
fights and really funny comedians and
screen junkies they come in pitch every
week there's two rounds three comedians
competing you fire one in the first
round and then the two go on to the
final round to pitch a blind pitch it's
very fun I'm excited for you all to see
it it's gonna premiere like Doug said
end of August early September yeah and
the winner every guest gets a bottle of
water and the winner gets their parking
validated like any real is that's how
Hollywood works they don't validate you
for working unless you unless the pitch
gets bought okay so yeah so that's
that's basically the idea of the show
and I hope you guys check it out right
yes please check it out it's so I'll get
September and yeah we have we have a
bunch of episodes and I tweeted us tell
us who you want to see on pitch off
those you watched online those you hear
in the crowd tell us us see what you
want to be pitched we're gonna be taking
your ideas as we shoot more episodes
with Doug so I'm excited thank you Doug
thank you and yeah screen junkies of
Doug Benson I love it Joe star are you
excited you did it what did you think
yeah it was a guest yeah I had to pitch
a really weird 80s comedy sequel and you
threw a lot at me yeah we throw a lot of
curveballs at the can spoil it
are we spoil yeah yeah I had to pitch
Ferris Bueller's week off with a Matt
Besser it was a it was pretty intense
and I tried to go the really hard
Christopher Nolan a sci-fi route which
yeah it was terrible right now yeah I
must have been in a mood you're just in
a mood for some Nolan we can take him
for having that noise in every movie now
thanks inception is it is that the Nolan
noise or is the Zimmer noise oh I don't
I can't give specific credit to anyone I
just I just started about
in Inception because it every seems like
okay this I get it this is intense well
it carries over to every trace may or
may not be a dream right now what's
happening I'm glad we cut him out of
your show but yeah you we did a good job
on there and yeah well get lots of fun
fun guests to come out in speaking of
fun cash I do bring some fun Gary yeah I
brought some of my friends down because
I thought we can't spend the whole this
whole period we have for this particular
show 45 minutes or so we can't spend the
whole time just talking about pitch off
so I thought we'd do a little mini Doug
loves movies right here and now and
three of my and your favorite guests
from Doug loves movies are here so let's
give a big warm welcome to Clara Kramer
Jonah ray and Graham Elwood the VIP
section so glamorous so exciting and
let's see what happens with the
microphones because there's too many to
choose no man pick from which one do you
want guys I'm good I got two mics I'm
ready to go oh there he goes mister
let's do this I can handle
Claire was it was a real specific
decision to not sit next to Doug what
was up with that
yeah to me I feel really sure yeah it's
a very impressive desk they brought in
for this yeah yeah we didn't have enough
mics yesterday now we have too many mics
but at least me alright we'll save him
up welcome guys thank you so much I
would have sat by you Doug but I heard
what was going on there the tables yeah
just I just want to know I'm not gonna
change my the way I behave at all yeah
I'll probably be a little worse this kid
right here we took a picture out in
front I'm like Jesus dad's a real good
role model dressing his kid up is flashy
getting him to take a picture with a
really slow guy
but we got Jose gonna help us out today
he's not just you know streaming some
stuff or watching things online he's
gonna help us out with I never have a
fact checker on Doug loves movies I've
just been checking Facebook yeah but
you're gonna check the facts for us and
the game we're gonna play in a minute so
that's why he's got his computer and
he's all all set to go
Graham Elwood hello hey what's going on
what do you what do you got going on at
Comic Con so last night is really cool
the Rick Myers superhero kung-fu
extravaganza he's been doing this for 19
years and he has myself and Chris
Mancini my co-host on comedy film nerds
talking about he shows clips of all
these insane martial art boys told this
one from the 70s called kung fu versus
yoga and there's a guy that a yogi that
puts his leg behind his head and his
foots right here and then kicks this guy
in the face it was the greatest thing
I've ever seen in my life
and I'm very excited not as much as
these people are they seem really
excited by it
they don't like high quality fighting so
I think it's easy to fight fine at Yoga
person cuz all you gotta do is wait for
them to do downward dog and then just
push them over yeah kick them in the
very vulnerable pose yeah I'm more
excited for the the sequel that's coming
out which is a yoga versus Pilates so
we're really getting fired up for that
Graham this isn't pitch off I don't need
to know your crazy ideas but how did you
like doing a pitch off you were one of
the first guests so I thought it was a
blast because you were acting like every
winged bird executive that any of us
have ever had to pitch to that throws in
crazy ideas so I love acting like me
yeah well that's how I deal with Doug
and on a daily basis hey Doug why don't
we go do shows in Cleveland what if we
brought a monkey all right
fine we'll go to Cleveland with a monkey
so I like pitch I like the whole selling
just go saying yes to whatever crazy big
you said I pitched speed3 I believe okay
it's about time we need to make that
happen
Claire Kramer's here everybody you
that's cool you didn't clap for me
whatever I get it I didn't say it right
I just started talking to you I should
have given you a grand mal what is here
you guys
but seriously Claire Kramer's here first
of all I didn't understand anything
about that yoga kung fu fighting
I have a question for you for pizza do
you get the do you get what you're
supposed to pitch prior to the show or
is it like you draw it out of a hat and
then you start you say we'll say
something like you have to pitch Ferris
Bueller's week off and and then we'll
give well know before they even come in
and we'll skip them a couple different
like variables that need to be included
in the page and then they put together
whatever they want and then the second
round if the whoever makes the two
players that make it to the second round
then they then we just give them
something on the spot that they have to
pitch on oh thanks they have to pitch in
front of each other so they could sort
of hear one guy do the pitch and then
and then the girl or whoever men and
women this isn't a sexist program
whatever Doug likes the best though gets
the pitch first but it's important
though we're keeping all the guests are
white because because every Studios job
is to hold down everybody every other
ethnicity and so I want to keep that
going got it now just worked out that
way right we just had all white people
in the first episodes but we'll fix that
don't you worry non-whites you're gonna
get your chance you know who you are
Claire what do you got what's going on
with you at Comic Con this weekend what
are you up to
I've been spending a lot of time at the
Marvel booth they was there live
yesterday and then at 2:00 o'clock today
I'm back at Marvel doing more stuff
doing Marvel stuff superheroes now with
Marvel's superhero stuff okay crazy
crazy Marvel MCU world things to do
anything fun I mean not that that's not
fun did you get to did you oh she went
saw Star Trek on Wednesday night for the
premiere when it's outside
oh great was that it was amazed
thing I really enjoyed it it was the
film I thought hit a really good balance
between old school like track and and
addressing like the humor that I feel
like has been missing from the last
iterations and then also like being
action-packed
which isn't traditional track but it's
kind of what we expect nowadays when we
go see a big-budget movies it's the most
action-packed start it's my plus an
economy yeah it's my favorite one since
Star Trek four so yeah I could fight you
on that well yeah there's a movie fight
throwdown
let's do it but uh no I really loved it
and I thought the presentation was great
there was great having a live orchestra
play the whole thing it was great it was
like seamless I forgot they were even
doing it which I feel like is this huge
compliment to the orchestra you think
but they were doing the whole for the
whole the whole thing it was amazing
laser lightshow there was fog there was
fireworks they go blind no good maybe
one well yeah that Justin Lin sure is
good with the action so that's that's
exciting it's gonna be good we'll say
this I know when the first trailer
dropped everybody was you know like this
is not the Trek movie we want to see and
I agreed actually at that point so did
Simon Pegg and everyone kind of was like
this didn't come off the right way when
you see the movie you realize where the
song came from and you realize where the
motorcycle so much better in the movie
and it makes sense and I can forgive the
fact that they cut that I just feel bad
they you know they want people back but
they should have released a different
first trailer they wanted the Fast and
Furious crowd to come yeah at that first
trailer and I think everyone admitted
that was why would you want that crowd
like we got to get the Fast and Furious
people over to Star Trek exactly you
have to he's pitching yoga sweet corona
sponsorship if you get the fast
affliction shirt guys you get a lot of
really solid people with the Fast and
the Furious it was a good movie for what
it was which one you know II seven of
that the seven and actually I thought
about this you know rest in peace to
Anton Yelchin
and I thought I was wondering if they
would have had more time if Justin would
have done something like he did for Paul
Walker and you know cutting together
like previous things maybe like well
yeah that could obviously also be the
next installment because there were a
couple for often running again it's
gonna be there's gonna be Star Trek's
from now on yeah well they've just
announced with Chris Hemsworth coming
back for the next one there you go
Kirk's dad coming back in time which is
good for was exactly exactly so this
Star Trek 4 is gonna go so now we're
gonna get crazy rules with the it's like
turning into Doctor Who a little bit
okay
Jonah ray is here you guys oh he's
almost I think both of us forgot that he
needs an introduction I just I know the
rules you're not supposed to talk abut
Beacon till spoken to exactly I've
gotten yelled at you too much in my life
to forget yes hello thank hello
everybody hey new host of Mystery
Science Theater 3000 won a Space Odyssey
where they were an Indonesian go for it
works I guess
yeah and but you're the new host and you
got new robot friends yeah yeah the
voices of CRO and servo are gonna be
played by Hampton Yount and Baron von
who are very funny comedians they're
good friends of mine so very excited
about that Felicia Day is the new mad
and then Patton Oswalt is the new he's
TV son of TV's Frank so it's a it's a
it's a good and the movies are
horrendous just real bad real real bad I
had no idea that the making the show was
also what the show is actually about
it's like you do have to suffer through
these movies yeah you have to go through
that bring the experience to everyone
else yeah definitely yeah so he really
really was imprisoned yeah we have a
question over here I'm just curious
because that you said the movies how do
you aren't we out of old movies they did
so like how do you how are they finding
the movies this time and are there any
like new or like you're gonna do the
room and stuff no no it's it's still
classic rest room just we have fun
to make jokes during well the the
RiffTrax is doing a pretty good job of
new movies and they're so great at that
and and this is like classic era Mystery
Science Theater the same kind of old you
know cheese that you're used to from the
original series there you know there's
still there's always going to be some
weird Italian or Danish or Korean
monster movie that no one ever saw you
know there's always gonna be something
out there
turns out they make movies all the time
we just don't see all of them and when
did when and where can people see it
we're not announcing where people can
see it for a little bit but you'll
you'll most likely be able to see it
okay yeah basically it's none of your
business
yeah going around making this whole
thing up Hampton jumped Berenbaum what
are these names classiest person ever if
you put all their names together and if
Aaron Hampton
alright so I'd like to play a game from
Douglass movies if everybody's cool with
that and I'd like to make Andy
participate he's never been on know
these but can we you and I switch seats
yes so that you guys are all in a row
and I don't get infused it'll be a lot
easier that way and we're gonna play a
newest game on the show because Jonah
and Graham and Claire are all veterans
of Douglas movies but I don't think any
of them have played this game before so
I'm gonna talk everybody through it it's
called how high can you get no we're not
gonna don't worry about the children
it's just a fun name for the game I'm
gonna name a topic a kind of film genre
of films and then we'll start down on
the end there with you Graham
and we'll you know we'll move the order
down one each time so the same person
doesn't get to go first every time and
Graham you have to name a movie and you
have to get the title exactly right
that's we've got a fact checker right
there to deal with this stuff so you
can't talk your way out of it
and you have to say a title of a movie
that's just got one word in the title
that fits into the genre that I we pick
then Claire's got to come up with a
different one then Jonah's got to come
up with one then Andy then the next
round we start with Claire and you have
to name a movie in that genre with two
words in the title and we see who can
get the highest who can get to the
highest one word title one word is the
first round weight one word title not
one more title one word in the title
that reflects the topic huh I think both
of those things you say mean the same
thing it's a one word title or a title
with only one word in it got it I'll
take the ladder and yeah but we're gonna
do the same Jean or all the way through
so you can start thinking ahead for your
twos and your threes and fours got it
yeah
book it let's do it same genre for all
the rounds yeah okay great it is
actually yeah but it'll get it'll get
tough and easy at the same time and
don't worry guys if there's any such
like if Slimer comes in here and starts
eating all of our hot dogs there's a
Ghostbuster right in the front row who's
ready to go and it's a dude Ghostbuster
so I don't know what's happening now
going back to the man already I see a
lot of women in those outfits here all
right Graham the topic is we're at Comic
Con has to be comic book movies movies
based on comic books name one that's
just got one word in its title Thor
great job Claire Superman yeah one word
doesn't even have a hyphen in it Jonah
spider-man Oh Hulk very gay I thought of
something ahead of time
spawn say blank man but I can't - Asians
count I I think that would still be one
word if it's got a high
I think but that's why we have Joe here
oh you're asking that yes don't don't
ask they act as a single idea yeah I
guess that's - rated word is a word is
one word okay great okay which one was
just called Hulk Oh was just go home Wow
yeah that's why people didn't go cuz
there wasn't there like it's not
incredible thing of Hulk is this in the
past it's been incredible yeah just hope
this is the mass yeah all right yeah
it's just fat Jim Carrey angry Jim
Carrey and shorts grin I even start
clearing this round to word title comic
book based movie I gotta go ant-man
now that's definitely got a hyphen in it
I checked that out ahead of time so
let's try again okay The Avengers don't
wanna we're not gonna mess around with
the word Marvel's at the beginning of
the then you can go ahead and pull that
out
Jonah two words American Splendor nobody
claps in the audience man not one that's
a Jones too late super underrated movie
I dare say one of my favorite got based
on a comic all right Andy Batman Begins
I think I know where Graham's gonna go
with this Dark Knight no how about
Batman Forever yeah okay because that
Dark Knight is the Dark Knight yeah oh
who gets to say a three word title first
you Jonah three word title yeah but yeah
doesn't go
hey comic book movies movies they always
been great at not helping so keep it
yeah keep doing that don't ya keep doing
that any answers
keep doing going out in round three you
no no no I'm not we just say one he just
said it what oh yeah Dark Knight Rises
shut up
target Knight Rises I just got that okay
fair enough that counts x-men first
class yeah Dark Knight Rises it's too
many words Dark Knight Rises I can't
take mine yeah you can yeah I don't want
to set it too fast or you can take that
was the one he said no we did it it was
theirs shut up you lose all my nerd cred
in one fell swoop and it's all your
fault ugh the second one was called so
tired
the it's the begins and then it's the I
love watching somebody else actually
over it is hard to play movie trivia
what
he's telling him what to do and he can't
do it unbelievable it rhymes with mark
night the dark dark night night
now that's not it that's not it that's
not it I didn't want to just cheat by
using though you guys could go ahead and
use your the I was trying to be a bit
better I'm trying to take the doff when
he's for two words when he says that so
all right so you you last one more round
no more leniency on my part all right I
apologize boss now I can't putz around
and first class x-men first class yes
x-men is one word cuz it's - right rule
we established good job ice gram wait a
second you're gonna start thinking now
through that whole conversation with
Jonah you could have been really picking
out some good ones no you were too busy
making fun of me now look at you it's
always comedy first with him
Star Trek beyond there you go it was a
comic book and an animated series so
we're good you're good
cuz that was one of the ones I was
considering if you took the Incredible
Hulk the Incredible Hulk
yeah bang pow very good done killed it
man so now we move on to for the for
Randy Thor the dark world who was a
giggle in the crowd but I thought it's a
pretty legit handsome The Dark Knight
Rises there you go I had big hero 6 for
my three word one yeah player four words
Avengers age of Ultron mmm-hmm I thought
it was the Avengers
there's no listen I you is that your
project I try what
you build yourself up don't tear others
down I'm not trying I just I'm so scared
and I'm lashing out it's all fear-based
for words somebody's suggesting
something in the audience even though I
said don't say anything yeah
four words no one was saying anything
before I said don't say any time it's
like I gave them the idea to say things
you can do it
transformers age of extinction
transformers is a comic book first
oh we're gonna allow Star Trek we got to
allow it sweet they're pretty amazing
how many movies there are that are
actually just based on comic books and
we have to bend the rules just to keep
you in the game five words Gramm Star
Trek the motion picture yes that's a
very good one that's right
Claire hold on one second right gotta
start counting them up in your head
I try to tell everybody to think way
ahead at the beginning of the game
because it's always good to have them
load it up ready to go everybody in the
audience has one raise your hands if you
have one okay when I said everybody I
meant seven or eight people it's hard so
next one okay I've got a lot of fours
now somebody just said I've got two
I'm killing it in the audience are you
going on the Internet's Andy has a lot
of things he has to deal with he's
producing all these shows here today can
we say what's coming up in the hittin
here next danny McBride's coming up next
and the bride is the next few guys are
in the crowd stick around you're gonna
catch David right Joanie Joanie here to
talk about Vice Principals on HBO
anything clear I don't know I always
feel like Timothy Olyphant and go when I
talk to her
Claire five words what is he doing Oh
signaling to somebody quite subtly sorry
check your phone check your phone can
pick up your white courtesy phone I
wasn't cheating
I think Claire's out coming yeah Jonah
Batman versus Superman dawn of Justice
what what still cheek her head in the
middle of it that's six wait what is
that Batman versus Superman dawn of
Justice Matt six words so there's one
more word sorry Batman V Superman say
get faster doesn't make it less fun do
letters count as words
well that letter represents the word
that word versus does it good try though
andis looking one up what do you got I
didn't Star Trek the voyage home Graham
what is it to me six now because I
already did I started the fives Oh it'll
be a TV show yeah also that's my
favorite that don't yell out answers
then the yell out summers doesn't make
any sense at all Cheers
maybe that's why they feel they could
get away with it no we start with we
move down
the line so Joan has to go first for six
cuz you went first four five right yes
right yeah six Jonah I already did one
what I already did my sex Batman versus
Superman
see out you need to get through the next
round oh you're already out Batman vs
Superman
there you go can't we strike it from the
record we can't have that can't have it
Graham what do you got oh man I've been
racking my brain for some sixes well I
had a good five the League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen you where you're
located no that's what's your twenty or
just what's your six and what's your 20
no I got things I got your six means I
got your back let's eighty-six this
conversation well I've got your 20
because I know where you are I'm going
to say the film that I'm talking about
that has six words in the title all
right you're out no yeah you are no Star
Trek to the Wrath of Khan numbers count
as a word yeah
Star Trek to the Wrath of Khan no wrath
of is a Klingon word six real quick oh
do you have a 6 and yet other than the
one you have another 6 yeah let's hear
it
Superman for the quest for peace that's
a good one alright so Andy's our winner
today he wins nothing one
Fantastic Four rise of the Silver Surfer
eight Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles out
of the shadows and I couldn't figure out
a 9 but I figured out of 10 Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles to the secret of
the ooze yeah all right let's do some
plugs we got to get out of here cuz you
got another great
panel coming up Graham what do you want
to plug the Los Angeles podcast festival
this September 23rd through the 25th a
bunch of people are in it Jonah's in it
Doug's done it in the past go to LA pod
fest calm and then of course my podcast
comedy film nerds it's available on
iTunes and you can go to comedy film
nerds dot-com and all my tour dates and
everything or at Grandma wood and
grandma would calm thank you yeah clear
yeah just hold your applause till the
end nothing no clap for me just just
follow me on Twitter at Claire Kramer at
geek nation and lar e Kramer no I know I
in there slam
yeah spelling them I was thinking sure
they knew mr. Sancerre will be coming
out later in the year I have a show
called hit America with Jonah ray on the
CSO network and the third season of the
meltdown with Jonah and Kumail comes out
come is central in September one
courtroom courtroom movies one word nuts
two words the judge three words Kramer
vs Kramer four words and justice for all
[ __ ] that's how good I am at this game
jeez yeah I just want to plug pitch off
stretch off yes member and thank you
Doug for doing this thank you guys so
much for coming to this panel thank you
for being screen junkies and we'll see
you soon yes stick around next danny
mcbride thank you guys so much
again to mafia 3 for sponsoring this
episode to watch our previous show click
the box to the left and to see
everything from screen